welcome to this you're going to the
airport today currently in the car
once on the way to San Francisco I am
playing this really basic app best Swift
before the conference so I'm not wasting
hard time so we're stuck on the airport
for like seven hours so I thought I'd
get some work out this is my you want a
launch at this excited to get some of it
definitely growing up I actually did not
have any idea that I was gonna end up
being a developer or a designer I never
thought that I could actually code and
make proper apps because it was somebody
else's thing whilst he is a skiing app
that we made it's a game where animals
come from the jungle and go to the
mountain my first game that I posted
it's called Operation brain growing up I
always hated math I think the way that
it's presented to us it's like a prison
it's a cage apps can change education
and we need that well I have two apps
that are on the App Store one is a game
called nightly moves that's based on
chess and then I have another app called
healthy food compass which will help you
find healthy food on the go right now I
am developing my first solo app it's
called a president it's going to allow
people to look at track follow discover
the presidential events for the 2016
election
[Music]
take yourself
[Music]
congratulations told you look at your
outfits fantastically cry
[Music]
for someone who changed my site
what are we doing I've been watching it
from home for the past couple of years
and I really want to see it wise I'm
eager to see how it's actually going to
be and feel the real experience
[Music]
our youngest scholarship winner is a
twelve-year-old girl from New York Tim
Cook mentioned me it felt really awesome
that I just stood out I've always heard
about it like oh my god all of these
people want to go to the keynote and all
that and then to even be able to go
there was just amazing I never expected
to be here at any point in time when I
started I never expected it to take me
places like this I'm just so excited to
use this new skill set towards the
things that I believe one thing I would
say to a girl who is just starting is
that don't give up just because it's
dominated by men because in the future
I'll hopefully be more woman and
including I would tell her girl also to
reach out to people to talk about her
app get all their feedback because from
one email we ended up here so not to be
afraid to share with the world her app
and what it does and then who knows
where that's going to take and I'm
really looking forward to continuing on
this journey I have no plans on stopping
[Music]